mais pour commencer le préfet réagit
après les pétitions des comités de
quartier dénonçant l'insécurité à tour
oui il veut montrer qu'il les a entendu
et pour cela il a mis sur pied une
opération d'envergure avec les forces de
l'ordre une centaine de policiers dont
60 CRS et une brigade cinophile sont
arrivés en renfort à tour et resteront
quelques jours hier ces policiers ont
ciblé en particulier les quartiers de la
retonde et du Sanitas ainsi que de tour
nord avec pour objectif premier une
présence mass et la lutte contre le
trafic de stupéfiants Aurélie Renaud et
Florent Clavel le chien traque les
moindres recoins de la cage d'escalier
mais ici pas de stupéfiant caché
quartier rotonde trois immeubles ont la
visite de la brigade cinophile dehors
six camions de la crs8 de Bièvre une
unité spécialisée dans les violences
urbaines au total une centaine de
policiers sont présents le dispositif
est important une réponse visible du
préfet au tourangeau en quête de plus de
tranquillité je ne prétends pas mettre
fin au trafic en tout genre mais je veux
rassurer les habitants du saditas et
d'autres quartiers de tour sur le fait
que la police est là elle reviendra il y
a de l'immigration illégale il y a des
squats il en reste une dizaine donc moi
dès que j'ai une décision de justice
s'il y a des étrangers en situation
régulière on les contrôle et si possible
on les interpelle quartier du Sanitas un
vendeur à la sauvette est interpellé le
reste du temps les policiers procèdent à
de nombreux contrôles d'identité devant
les passants moi je pense que c'est très
bien ça pourrait nous rassurer vu la
délincance qu'il y a partout bah ça
permet de de sécuriser les gens de de la
ville donc nécessaire qu'il a la de de
la police le préfet a un objectif de
présence et de visibilité la police
occupe le terrain le but perturber les
trafics de drogues on a des drogues de
synthèse on a de la cocaïne on a de
l'héroïne on a tout ce ce type de de
produits qui qui circulle et contre
lesquel on a une action résolue et et
permanente en début de soirée la
centaine de policiers se rendent à tour
nord la démonstration de force du préfet
n'est pas du goût de tous les habitants
notamment lorsqu'un jeune homme
multipliant les provocations se fait
arrêter par plusieurs policiers nous ça
nous dange pas qu'il des qu' des flics
dans la ville ils sont là pour faire
leur métier assurer la sécurité et
cetera mais là ils abusent un petit peu
je trouve autant de force pour ça autant
de personnes pour ça c'est c'est inutile
je trouve l'unité CRS restera une partie
de la semaine hier les policiers ont
contrôlé 78 personnes et en ont
interpellé
de